not a rhetorical question i would like
you
to think back to last week
and when we introduced vector equations
of lines
not a rhetorical question why did we
introduce vector
equations we've been dealing with lines
for years we've got equations of lines
why vector equations any takers
does anyone recall hm
you're going to start us off so you have
one variable lambda instead of three x
like that
okay so that's a big idea here let's
just jot that down
we introduced this lambda it had a
special name by the way which um
didn't mention starts with a p doesn't
remember what it's called it's called a
parameter
right so we introduce this lambda this
parameter
and we introduce it in place of
three different variables a single
variable right rather than an x
and a y and a z and that kind of is was
the main reason do you remember
we're trying to represent lines in three
dimensions and we were like ah
awkward to come up with equations just
like normal cartesian equations for
these
lines not impossible just we ended up
with planes when we tried to
extend what we do in 2d into 3d right
now we're going to keep on going with
vector equations because it turns out
they're not just
handy to represent three-dimensional
stuff they're very very useful for
representing things that you just cannot
come up with a cartesian equation for
however to get better at working with
vector equations
we're going to go into if you have a
look at this question here for example
we're going to go into
using vector equations but in 2d just so
we can wrap our head around them
3d is really hard when you just start to
add a little bit of complexity
so when you have a look at this question
as we're going to do right now think
about this you may like to jot
for yourself as i'm reading a bit of a
diagram for yourself
so how does it begin you get some line
v it gets a vector equation
2 comma sorry two comma one two one
what kind of vector is that for this
particular line
it's a particular kind of vector it's
the position vector because it gets us
onto the line
and then you've got this lambda as jiao
mentioned 1
2 and that's a different vector what
vector does that represent
it's the direction vector very good so
if you're starting to assemble for
yourself a diagram right
that 2 1 2 horizontal 1
vertical that tells you that gets onto
the line position vector
and then the one two one horizontal
two vertical that tells you the
direction which way you're facing do you
have a sense for the gradient of the
line now
it's simply going to be rise over run
it's upside down because we go x and
then y
gradient two okay so we've got a
straight line great
it intersects the circle with center and
then they provide you this is a bit
funny right
they provide you a vector that tells you
where the center is
vector which we sort of normally
associate with oh it's this line bit but
really it's the point
at the end it's the head as it were of
the vector that tells us where the
center of the circle is
radius 3 and then apparently this line
and this circle intersect twice
p and q the midpoint of that
chord pq is m find the coordinates of
them there's the question
okay now let me give you a brief moment
there's so much and i already mentioned
draw a diagram
right there's so much visually going on
here that you really cannot
successfully enter this question without
having a decent diagram
up your sleeve that takes some time and
thought that is its own part of the
question even though it's not
i let's say draw a diagram right so let
me give you a minute now i can see like
bits of diagrams beginning you
absolutely absolutely need to use a
ruler
um the bigger this is the better it's
going to be for you i can see a few like
20 cent piece
circles there i'm going to tell you
right now too small i will show you my
diagram in about 60 seconds but that
will give you some opportunity
to draw your own okay off you go
okay now i'm just going to point out
right
i have a distinct advantage off of you
because
having drawn on a tool like this i can
draw things like perfect circles
and get all my scale perfectly right
little things like for example
have a have a look at how i've
positioned everything right have a look
at that straight line
for instance right the line is 2 1
plus lambda 1 2. can you see on my
diagram
all this orange stuff which enabled me
to construct where it was
right do you see the position vector uh
two one so i went
two one bam that black point i'm on the
line now
yeah and then i look at the direction
vector and then i say ah
it's the next orange one right i go one
two so this is me working out where does
the line go
where does it face okay um i can do that
perfectly i actually have a i use the
grid behind this in order to do it
properly
um and then i can say well now i'm going
to think about this circle
right think about the circle and how i
construct it again crucial information
center one negative two
and then i've got a radius again i have
this distinct advantage that i can do it
perfectly which we're not going to
expect you are able to do normally just
with a
even if you've got a pair of compasses
or something like that but the important
thing is
do you have positioned roughly what it
is you're trying to find
you've got your p and your q there right
i've put them in in blue and what's the
actual thing i'm after
it's m right that's that's what i'm
trying to locate and so that's why you
can see helpfully
i've got that there i'll be able to do a
sense check afterwards when i get an
answer for this
if i'm in the right ballpark okay now
how do i go about this
now there's at least two distinct pretty
solid methods you could use
you could think of this because we've
given you straight lines circles
you could do this all in cartesian terms
right you could get a cartesian equation
for that circle
you could get a cartesian equation for
that line it's not too difficult for
example if you just look here oopsie
daisy sorry
if you just look here um it's not
difficult to work out that that's the y
intercept
of this and you sort of already have the
gradient in your mind so you could do
that
come up with cartesian equations for
everything and off you go okay
i've got the cartesian solution for this
if we have time i've got another example
after this we might have a look at it
but for now the whole point of us
looking at this question is to try and
wrap our hand
around how do we use vector equations to
come up with this
m okay so hold on to your hats let's try
and solve this
together the equation of a circle
in vector terms is remarkably similar to
the equation of a circle
on the complex plane
think about this with me i wonder if you
can think back to term four right if i
ask two for instance let's keep it nice
and simple
to tell me the complex plane
equation of say the unit circle just a
nice basic one
what would its equation be it's very
very simple
i'll give you a clue it's got a z in it
i'm helpful like that absolutely okay
i'm going to have a modulus of z
right which it represents distance from
the origin
okay so distance from here and in order
to get all the points on the
circumference what do i want that
distance to be
for the unit circle it's just one right
now it's not difficult to make this
not the unit circle all i have to do is
make it say bigger or smaller
just change that to whatever radius you
want so far so good
that's exactly the same idea over here
in vector equations right
z we can think of we even did this back
in term four we can think of z
in vector terms okay so therefore you
might want to jot this down right
the equation of a circle that is
centered on the origin
is going to look exactly the same as
that except instead of z which is
our notation for complex numbers we
would use the modulus
or the absolute value of well
whatever vector you want right
the modulus for some vector is going to
equal
some particular radius that's what i've
got over there does that make sense
so here is a circle centered on the
origin with some
given radius okay now
think back to over here right what if i
didn't want a circle centered on the
origin what if i wanted to say
i don't know move it one unit to the
let's go this way actually one unit to
the right
okay suppose i wanted it over here
centered at one
what would i do to this equation it
won't be mod z anymore
yeah we might say again again
yeah fantastic mod of z minus one and
then whatever radius
right because what this does is it says
instead of looking
from the origin now i'm looking from one
and then i compare that distance okay
that's going to be exactly the same deal
over here except i've just got a
slightly off center right so this
particular circle i'm going to have
not just the distance to this vector to
the end point
but it's the distance offset by whatever
your center is supposed to be
which in this case is 1
negative 2. does that make sense do you
see how i mean i didn't have to do
minus 1 i could have done minus i or
minus 1 plus 2y i could go anywhere on
the complex plane
and here in the same way i've just gone
anywhere in these two dimensions just
offset by whatever you want your center
to be
what's my radius in this question
there's three bam
unlike the cartesian equation which has
an r squared in it from pythagoras this
is just
ah i just want the distance that's the
distance it's three
tada okay